rather than ask you what your dream
superpower would be for the pill to
unlock i want to know what is the most
boring but
practical superpower you would really
want
making pancakes really well like really
amazing pancakes
i love pancakes okay personally um so
yeah i mean for some people that would
be boring for
others like myself that's not boring at
all that's amazing
i love pancakes now i really wanted to
dig into the details of what it was like
filming that fight sequence in
particular the shot that's done from
inside the tank is a moment like that
for you
just about hitting your marks kind of
doing a dance in a sense
yes especially because in this film
there's very
very little uh cgi most of it
is practical you know stunts and and
it's very
uh realistic and we shot a couple
of times a lot
shot a lot that one we shot a lot um
but it was all about uh choreography
ballet and and trying to manage and we
were very focused we
rehearsed and we did a couple of times
and then again
and then we came back to it and then we
did it again
and they got a lot of pcs and and but
it's beautiful i
the result is really beautiful the
sequences it carries and it's
it's amazing uh it was a lot of work a
lot of work behind but we were so proud
when we finally
when they finally said we got it guys
and we were like
we were really really happy it was a
tough one
now i want you to tell me about biggie's
big
look i imagine there has to be some cg
involved in that
so where do you come in in terms of
shaping
that design for the final film that's a
makeup artist from new york
called mike marino he's a genius
and i wore a suit at
four pieces and i spent nine hours in
the chair
the first day to get ready and i did
everything it's me doing everything
wearing
you know a suit a three-piece suit
and then pieces on the neck and pieces
on the face
i shaved my whole face and i had like
left of my this side of my mustache that
was the only thing i had and then the
rest
hair is fake it's all makeup and then
body work
doing you know the guy if we had time i
would pull my cell phone right now
and you would see what i'm talking about
but we don't have it but you'll see
thanks so much for digging into all that
with me congratulations project power
best